here's the thing Emma for you what is
the hold that the Spice Girls have over
you is this real yes it's real
and I just feel like I've been talking
more about the Spice Girls on this press
tour than I have about the movie you
well yeah I know I wept
did you really we I really did but no
which one was talking to you Mel B I'm
when she really told you was it a
message no it was a video message on an
iPad and that made you cry
what were you jet-lagged I mean you do
understand because we're in the UK yeah
I was I was a fiend I was obsessed with
the Spice Girls and they taught me about
girl power and I love them I think
they're fantastic and I miss the song
there's so many Jamie there's so many
like there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio Mel C
talked to me over Skype oh so it's
really very exciting okay who would you
say is your favorite Spice Girl Emma
Bunton babies wife she's your favorite
who's next
just a question all of the other four
so ever Bunton well Emma Bunton was the
one that I had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is now Emma my name
was Emily but it was taken when I became
an actor and now Emma and yeah I just
love so get me this so you one
gave you a video message and one talked
to you on skype yes what are you telling
me you've never met have you never seen
to be something really have you never
met a Spice Girl I'm wait hold on
have you never met a Spice Girl riding
the flash okay now as you know
[Music]
it's very rare it is very rare for more
than one spice girl to appear together
[Applause]
[Music]
sort of prank stories on the sofa I
doubt anyone can top Kate Beckinsale's
this is such a genius prank and I sort
of hate asking you to tell us because I
would so like to do it to someone yeah
and this will spoil it go okay it was in
a very impromptu one because I'd I'd
been if somebody falls asleep next to me
it's dangerous because I like to glue
beards to them or draw tattoos or
whatever it is pirates the Caribbean
beard all that and I'd run out of things
like that and and yet I was still after
the rush of doing I got into bed and I
think I've got a little you know one of
those chocolates that that you get by
the bed oh you know and I thought how
funny would it be if I just tucked it in
between the person's buttocks while
they're asleep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
isn't that so good
it just took a very organically can I
said my eyes bet on the chocolate and I
kind of did that and I see the sleeping
bottom here and then I thought I'm just
going to do it and I tucked it in I
thought maybe I'd get in trouble in the
morning but it was a very fortuitous day
because this was the morning where the
person was in a terrible rush and just
went straight into the pants and the
trousers and straight to work so halfway
through the day at work there was there
got all backwards to live and then the
horror horror I've done this without
even feeling
[Applause]
it smells so minty I didn't know it's
going to go that far I thought it was
just going to be the morning but it just
sort of unfold so well just sleeping mix
there's surely a friend of someone I
didn't know
did you feel bad no I was absolutely but
I did not indeed I loved him dearly but
I thought I was gonna have the thing in
the morning of Oh Kate you put chocolate
in my chocolate it wasn't it wasn't a
Toblerone
[Laughter]
the person was it did other people
notice their benefit of their - it was
their shock not others who was Butler
who were behind them to see the results
of their
muzzled on the top central place fallout
zone tonight
in the night between a pair of buttocks
it's going to just sort of soften out
because when your co-stars were here
yes monuments man Matt Damon oh my god
that show about how mean you were to him
on set though so you didn't torture
these people because famous you've this
ongoing thing with Brad Pitt so I've
done some terrible things to probably
wait Brad's not some terrible things to
meet so how did it start
I don't remember how we were doing
Ocean's eleven I think it was the first
one and I don't remember what it was
I I think initially you I get one of my
favorite things is to get those things
that go around your license plate or a
bumper sticker cuz you never go to the
back of your car and look and put it on
people's cars cuz it's funny and they
can ride around you know with some
horrible you know embarrassing bumper
sticker and I put I found a bumper
sticker in the shape of a pot plan that
said [__] cops
because I figure that's not the way you
don't get pulled up there's no you got
and he went on I think Letterman and
said you know let me ask him when he and
Angie would get married he said when
George can legally marry in the United
States and they just kept going back and
forth with that for a while and then it
was I had stationery made up with his
name and then I would send letters to
other actors I sent Meryl Streep a
letter from Brad where I got a big thing
of CDs that had died it was a dialect
coach and he had like every dialect you
know Jalen Yiddish every dialogue you
buy in this huge thing and I sent it to
her with a note from Brad that said you
know I hear you're gonna be doing the
Iron Lady soon this guy helped me with
my dialect in Troy or somebody I thought
maybe this would help
I've sent letters so lots and lots of
people from Brad don't tell either I
don't tell either no I let her lie k
year met two years later I let him know
and then they're like are you kidding me
I'm doing one now that I can't tell you
about but in a year you're going to hear
that I've been arrested
that's exciting I have a wife she's a
barrister I'll be fine
what was the thing with Michael Jackson
this is such an odd story what oh he
just got into the habit of wherever I
was staying he'd just call the hotel and
asked my room and put on funny voices I
didn't I've never met him you know the
first couple of people that I said it to
I was like I didn't want to sound like I
was insane right Michael no prank called
me today when I actually started talking
people who really knew him well they got
many dozen all the time but it was like
yeah it was like everything I used to do
that when I was like 11 and 12 I used to
pretend I was a radio announcer and like
give people prizes I would get so
excited just hang up and go wow that was
a good job well done I made that pretend
to be Oh always start off being kind of
gruff like you were still Hotel
Management and there was some kind of
problem surprising and saying you're
Michael Jackson then if I got kind of
irritated you go
ladies like Naomi is so serious and
she's so focused on set that she never
sees the practical joke coming she never
sees like I didn't do you know I had a I
had a thing I had a little bit of a
injury it's called dog jaw yeah I don't
know do you have you ever
[Music]
[Applause]
people travel you know they collect
things postcards dolls and national
dress but you collect like animals like
like living animals I don't collect them
I rescue them oh did you rescue anything
when you were in Sicily in Tuscany not
in that one but in the movie I did right
after in Bulgaria I I did okay and I had
I had promised my husband I was gonna
stop because at the time I had ten dogs
five pirates
I had alpacas horses cats and by the way
one without a tail the other one without
a leg they always they find me they come
to me these animals which he doesn't
believe me but they do and I promise him
no more okay
we were up to thirty animals I swore no
more and I was there and a little puppy
who was abandoned and was gonna die I
won't tell you the sad story because
it's a comedic show and I'll start
crying he came to me and I couldn't help
and I picked him up
and his name is Ocho after the the
goalie of the soccer team in Mexico was
a welcome and I took him and then I was
terrified how am I going to explain this
to my husband I promised I promised and
so I came up with this brilliant idea to
pretend that I was having an affair with
somebody to make him think I was having
an affair and at the end I would say no
it's not an affair I picked up a dog and
then you would feel better
so I left him a message you must call me
at this time We Need to Talk it's very
important and I never do that and this
time okay what happened what happened
and I said listen I feel so terrible I
don't know how to say these to you and I
know this is not not gonna go down well
and I'm really nervous and please have
mercy on me because I should be
understanding it's just it's been so
stressful that I'm so tired and I was so
lonely here you do crazy things when
you're in this state and he said to me
oh please don't tell me you picked up
another dog
[Applause]
[Music]
you